how's it going everyone this is Daniel
from the chess website and today we are
going to be looking at an opening
commonly known as the four move
Checkmate it's also known as the
scholars mate and not only are we going
to look at this specific trap but we are
also going to be looking at how to
defend against it from Black's
perspective so I would definitely keep
that in mind especially if you're at
that level say under a thousand you're
going to occasionally have people try
this type of trap against you and not
only is it the Checkmate that you need
to watch out for but there might be some
other inaccuracies that you could
potentially play that would possibly
lead you to get a worse position so
without further Ado let's go ahead and
get started also I do apologize I don't
have my microphone with me so if the
audio is slightly off then that would be
the reason why so anyway the moves for
the scholars made as it's commonly known
is E4 E5 and white plays the move Queen
to H5 note that we are attacking the E5
Pawn so any move that does not protect
the E5 Pawn would be an inaccuracy if we
look at a few options the black can play
Black and try moves like Bishop D6 Queen
E7 Queen F6 but they all lead to
developmental disadvantages even to move
Pawn to D6 and we can look individually
D6 blocks the bishop although probably
would be a pretty solid Choice Queen to
E7 also blocks the bishop Queen to F6
blocks the Knight for moving and the
worst of them all probably is this move
G6 which is a pretty common mistake
among beginners and after the move G6 we
can play this move Queen takes E5
forking the king and the Rook black can
play Queen E7 but then we snag the rook
and then after Queen takes E4 we can
just play any move under the sun that
gets us out of check check we're doing
fine and we're up a rook not to mention
there going to be problems like
protecting the Knight and we're probably
going to get at least another Pawn out
of it and things like that so after this
move G6 we would just take E5 so the
best move for black is actually to
develop their other Knight to protect
the pawn so now we're unable to take the
pawn because the Knight protects it and
going back this move Queen H5 is almost
always going to signify
a potential Scholars mate attempt rarely
does someone play Queen H5 and then just
continue on with a normal developing
move normally they're going to try
Bishop C4 which aims at this F7 Square
so if black just plays a move like
Knight F6 then we play Queen takes F7
and get checkmate it's Checkmate because
the king if the king takes then the
bishop is protecting and there are no
other squares for the king to go to that
would be safe so after this move Bishop
to C4 again you can try Queen E7 Queen
F6 Knight H6 would defend Checkmate but
after a move like D4 you're kind of in
hot water because the bishop is
attacking the Knight which is protecting
mate so after Bishop to C4 the best way
to defend is now to play G6 note that a
move earlier G6 was a blunder because it
hangs E5 now we play G6 when it's
protected by the Knight so we're unable
to take the pawn because of the Knight
so after the move G6 White's normally
going to drop back Queen F3 and note
that even though we've kicked the queen
away they've renewed the threat of
Checkmate so we have to watch out the
most natural move in this position is
just to go Knight F6 so you go Knight F6
and then suddenly the Queen's looking a
little bit Exposed on F3 and you can
just play moves like Bishop G7 castles
Pawn to D6
and then eventually White's always going
to have a worse position because of the
placement of their Queen so it prevents
like their knight from developing it
could be vulnerable to attacks like
Bishop G4 like a a typical main line
here might go Knight E2 Bishop G7 and
then Knight B to C3 Bishop to G4 and I
actually believe if I'm not mistaken
this follows a Hikaru Nakamura game from
2005 that which Hikaru lost probably
because his Queen is Miss placed on F3
but that was 2005 that was so long ago
one attempt that white might try after
Knight to F6 granted an extremely
amateurish play might be an idea like G4
so that Bishop
G7 they can go G5 and then try to kick
the Knight away however after this move
Pawn to G4 black can just play Move Like
Knight D4 you're harassing the queen and
because you've played this move G4 you
have an extremely worse position
and yeah that's the four move Checkmate
or Scholars mate just to review the four
move Checkmate is E4 E5 Queen H5 Knight
C6 and then if they just ignore this
threat we get checkmate but the way to
defend is after you've played Knight C6
protecting the pawn now you play G6 then
you play Knight F6 and you just have a
better position from here so I believe
that's it as far as the for Checkmate
goes thank you so much for watching this
video I will see you guys for the next
one take
care